アーユシュマン・サスナマス
ヤデーワトワンラーフラワーチャヤ・カッマン・カットゥカーモー・ホーシ
タデーワテー・ワチー・カッマン・パッチ・ウェッキタッバン
ヤンヌコーアハン・イダン・ワーチャヤ・カッマン・カットゥカーモー
イダン・メー・ワチー・カッマン
アッタ・ビャーバーダーヤピ・サンワッテイヤ
パラ・ビャーバーダーヤピ・サンワッテイヤ
ウブハヤ・ビャーバーダーヤピ・サンワッテイヤ
アプサラン・イダン・ワチー・カッマン・ドゥック・ドッリャン・ドゥッカ・ヴィパーカン・ティ
で それでマーラーフラ尊者に言います
次に ワーチャヤ・カッマン・カットゥカーモー・ホーシ
言葉で何か行為をしたくなるでしょうと
で もしラーフルあなたは言葉で何か行為をしたくなる
しますと タデーワ・テー・ワチー・カッマン・パッチ・ウェッキタッバン
その時 その言葉でやりたがっている
行いたくなっているその行為について
ワチー・カッマン 言葉の行為ですね
それについてパッチ・ウェッキタッバン
観察するべきであると
観察しなさいと ヤンヌコーアハン・イダン・ワーチャヤ・カッマン・カットゥカーモー
まあ今私はイダンこの言葉を
言葉の行為をしたくなってますと
この言葉を語りたくなってますと
イダン・メー・ワチー・カッマン
イダン このメー・ワチー・カッマン
私の言葉の行為はアッタ・ビャーバーダーヤピ・サンワッテイヤ
自分の害になるものでしょうかと
もしかすると私自身の害になるでしょうかと観察するべきですね
それからパラ・ビャーバーダーヤピ・サンワッテイヤ
あるいは他人に害を与える
損を与える 他人に悪い影響を与える言葉でしょうかと観察するべきですね
パラ・ビャーバーダーヤピ・サンワッテイヤ
あるいは両方の 自分と他人の両方の害に値するものでしょうかと観察するんですね
で 観察したことで だからそのようなものだったら
アプサラン・イダン・ワチー・カッマン
この言葉の行為はアプサラ
不善である 罪であると
ドゥック・ドッリャン
苦しみを まあ済むんですね
苦しみを まあドゥック・ドッリャンとは苦しみが生まれてくるもので
ドゥッカ・ヴィパーカン
苦しみは結果としてなるものであると
結果として苦しみが生まれるものになるんだよと
で そういうふうに観察
考えるべきなんですね
で ヤンコーアハン・イダン・ワチー・カッマン・カットゥカーモー
メー・ワチー・カッマン
また重なり合ってますが
もし自分が言葉で行いたくなっている行為は
まあ簡単に言えばまあ喋ることなんですけど
言葉で行いたくなっている行為が
まあ自分のためにもならないし
他人のためにもならないし
両方のためにもならない
自分の害にもなる あるいは他人の害になる
あるいは両方の害にもなる
そうだったら エーワ・ルーパンテー・ラーフラ・ワーチャヤ・カッマン・ササッカンナ・カラニーヤン
そのような言葉の行為はササッカン
もう絶対 徹底的にも ナ・カラニーヤン
するべきではないと そのような言葉の行為は徹底的にやめた方がよろしいと
サチェー・パナトワン・ラーフラ・パッチ・ウェッカマーノ・エーワン・ジャーネーヤーシ
ヤンコーアハン・イダン・ワーチャヤ・カッマン・カットゥカーモー
イダン・メー・ワチー・カッマン・ネーワ・アッタ・ビャーバーダーヤ・サンワッテイヤ・ナ・パラ・ビャーバーダーヤ・サンワッテイヤ・ナ・ウブハヤ・ビャーバーダーヤ・サンワッテイヤ
それからラーフラ 自分でやりたがっているこの言葉の行為は
観察するとネーワ・アッタ・ビャーバーダーヤ・サンワッテイヤ
自分の害に値するものではありませんと見えてきます
あるいは他人の害に値するものではないと見えてきます
あるいは両方の害に値するものではありませんと見えてきます
その時は決断するんですね
クサラン・イダン・ワチー・カッマン
この言葉の行為はクサラン
善行為であると スクッドッリャン
幸福になるもので スッカ・ヴィパーカン
幸福が結果になるものであると
そこで決定して判断するんですね
エーワ・ルーパンテー・ラーフラ・ワーチャヤ・カッマン・カラニーヤン
そのように観察した結果
結論が出たならば そのような行為をやるべきであると
それは行為をする前になんですね
だから言葉の行為をする前にそういうふうに観察してみます
それは自分の害に与えるものか
他人の害に与えるものか
あるいは両方の害に与えるものかっていうふうに
次にカロンテーナピテーラーフラワーチャエカンマン
それからこの言葉の行為をするときは
行為を今やってるんですね
まずやっても良いと判断したところで
善行為であると分かったところで
その善行為をやるんですね
やってる時もその善行為を観察するべきなんですね
ヤン
ヌコーハンイダンワーチャエカンマンカロミイダンメワチーカンマンアッタビャーバーダーエピサンワッタティパラビャーバーダーエピサンワッタティウビャービャーバーダーエピサンワッタティ
で 言葉の行為を行っている時も
やってる最中でも この行為は私の害に与えるでしょうか
他人の害に与えるでしょうか
両方の害に与えるでしょうかと
ずっと観察しながら行為をするんですね
そこで今喋っている言葉の行為をしている最中ですけど
それでも観察し続ける
その時も発見する もしかすると
やっぱりこの行為は自分に害を与える行為である
他人に害の害を与える行為である
両方にも害を与える行為であると発見してしまうんですね
発見しちゃうと またそれがあそこで結論を出しますね
その行為はアクサランイダンワチーカンマンドクドラヤンドゥッカリパーカンという判決を出すんですね
この言葉の行為は不善であると
苦しみを作るものであると
サチェトアンラーフラパッチウィッカマナエワンジャーニーヤシ
ヤンコアンアクサランギダンワチーカマンドクッドゥアンドゥッカリパーカンパティサンハレイヤシトアンラーフラエーローパンワチーカンマ
ン そこで言葉を喋っている最中であろうとも
観察した結果 やっぱりこれは不善だと答えが出てくるならば
その時点ですぐそれはやめるべきなんですね
ストップするべきなんですね
行為を そこでそちらの反対の方法で
また行為 言葉の行為を行っている最中で観察していくと
やっぱりそれが自分の害に与えるものでもないし
他人に害を与えるものでもなく
両方にも害を与えるものではないと見えてきます
行っている最中で アヌパダジェイヤシトアンラーフラエーローパンワチーカンマン
そのような言葉の行為だったら
まあまあ続けてやってみなさいと
これはいい言葉だよと
みんな私のためにもなるし
他人のためにもなるし
両方のためにもなるいいことだよと
でわかったら まあそれは続けてやるべきですよと
それは行為を行っている真っ最中で
それから行為を終了してからも
また同じ 観察をするんですね
ヤンヌクワハンギダンワチャエカンマンアカシン
今私は言葉の行為をしてしまったんですがということで
その行為は私に害を与えるものでしたか
他人に害を与えるものでしたか
あるいは両方に害を与えるものでしたかと観察する
そうすると 害を与えたものであったとわかったら
そこでまた判決を出すんですね
あの もうとっくに終わってるんですけど
あの言葉の行為はアクサラン
不善でありましたと 苦しみを作るものであったと
結果として苦しみが生まれるものであったと判断するんですね
もしそこでこう もう もう行為終わってるんですよ
終わってからは もう観察したらしたところであ
これが悪いと 悪かったと
もう発見する 不善な行為をしたと発見する
その時はもうどうすればいいんですかと
もうやって終わってるんだからね
エールーパンテーラーフラワチーカンマンサッヘリワヴィンニュースワサブラマチャリースデセタッバン
そのようなことをやってしまったならば
サッヘリ釈尊に あるいはヴィンニュースワサブラマチャリース
自分と一緒に修行している智慧のある出家お坊さんたちに
デセタッバン 言うべきであると
ヴィワリタッバン あらわにするべきであると
隠してはいけないということなんですね
ウッターニーカータバン
ウッターニっていうのは上に上向くようにするという意味で
だから隠すんではなくて
ちゃんと報告しなさいと
自分が言葉で行為をしたんだけど
その行為は悪い行為でありましたと
そこでデセットワヴィワリットワウッターニーカーットワ
このように これは懺悔ですからね
そこをこういう過ちを犯しましたとちゃんと発表して
それからアーエティンサンワランアーパッジタッバン
アーエティン二度と同じような過ちを起こさないようにと気をつけるべきですと
エアンタイニサチエパナトゥアンラーフラパッチャウェックマノエワンジャーネーヤーシ
もし観察するとあなた発見するんだったら
アンコーイダンワチャエカンマンアカシン
私は言葉で何か行為をやって終わってしまったんですが
その私の言葉の行為はネーワアッタッビアバーダーエサンワッティティサンワッティ
私の害にもならなかったし
他人の害にもならなかったし
両方の害にもならなかったんですよと
その場合はクサランイダンワチーカンマン
この私が行った 行って終わった
その言葉の行為はクサラン
善行為でありましたと
ゆえに幸福は結果としてなるものでありましたと
テーナエーワトゥアンラーフラピーティパームッジェーナヴィーヘレイヤーサ
それであなたはいいことをしたんだということで
良いことできたということで
ピーティパームッジェー大変喜びを感じて
楽しみ 喜びを感じて ヴィーヘレイヤーサ
感じていなさいと 感じて生活しなさいと
それだけじゃなくてアホーラッターヌセッキー
昼も夜もラッタっていうのはもうすごい真剣ということで
真剣に頑張ってください
昼も夜もクセレースダンメース
善法 善たるものを実践することに
昼も夜もよく真剣に頑張ってみなさいと
アヌセッキーというのは一応修行するっていうかね
善行為をするようにと努力しなさいと
昼も夜も で このセットで説明しているのはこの言葉のことなんですが
まあそれぐらいで十分理解できると思いますけどね
現代社会のように大変複雑な
難しい 理解できないほどの道徳っていうのは
この遠い昔はあったわけじゃないし
だから単純に明確な話ですからね
説明する必要はない で
皆様方はそこで試験の道徳論と私は勉強したことはないので
それはちょっと何も言えませんですから
いろいろお話やってみてもよろしいと思いますけど
一応お釈迦様が言っているのはそれぐらいのことで
単純ではないかなと思いますけどね
言葉の行為というものの場合は
まず喋る前に それが人のために
自分のためになるものか
他人のためになるものか
あるいは両方のためになるものかと観察してみる
そういうことで 仏教はやっぱりこの
それも一つ嫌われる原因かもしれませんですけど
すぐ何かやるということはあまり認めてないんですね
まあやる前にちょっと考えてくださいと
ですから まあそれは現代社会の道徳から見れば良くないかもしれませんですけど
それはしょうがないんですね
昔の話ですからね やっぱりやる前に
行為をやる前に考えてみなさいというのは
それは昔の人々の考え方なんですね
ですから この すぐやるべきですよという
それが正しいという人々の考え方と
そこは合わないんですよ
ですから どちらが正しいかということは
まあ別に自由に判断するべきであって
とにかくお釈迦様の時代では
お釈迦様の道徳論では
やっぱり行為を行う前に
喋る前に考えてほしいんですね
で 皆様がディスカッションする場合は
そこら辺でもあらゆるポイントが出てくると思います
私は好き勝手にいろいろポイントを出し
喋ったところで ものすごく嫌われて
もう嫌になって批判されちゃって
もう迷惑だと この経典の勉強というところまで言われるんですよ
時間の無駄やと ということだから
やっぱりそこら辺は皆様の鋭い知恵でディスカッションした方がいいんです
一応問題点だけはね まあ定義しておきますけど
まあそんな喋る前に何喋るかとわかっているわけではありませんではないかとかね
もうそれは非科学的ですよと
人間っていうのは喋るときは淡々と喋るんではないかと
そこですごく淡々と純次に喋ることこそ人間の能力ではないかと
それで喋ったことはまずかったかなかったかということは
それはもう後のお話ではないかと
まず喋るべきですという立場もあります
なぜならば そんな喋ってもないのに
どうやって観察するんですかと
科学的に言えば まだ言葉が生まれてないんですね
法律的にもまだ言葉が成り立ってないんですよ
いわゆる存在しないんですね
科学的に見れば まだ喋ってないんだから
だから存在してもないものについて判決は出せますかと
妊娠もしていない人の子供が男か女かと判決出せるかというふうに
この現代思考でそういう考え方
反論が出せる で 一応問題ポイントだけは言っておきます
説明はしません ですから
喋るべきではないかと
とにかく喋ってからちゃんと客観的に科学的なデータとして喋った言葉がありますね
それで法律として あなたはこういう言葉を喋ったんだそうと
まあ録音 するなりに記録するなりに
ちゃんと証拠を物件とちゃんとしたもの
その時はあるんですね
その時ではないかと判決できる
ということを言えるんですね
そこで やっている時は判断しなさいと
真っ最中でも言うことにも異論が成り立つんですね
そうするともう喋れなくなるんではないかという問題も出てきますね
そんなもう喋る時はそれは無理ですと
ですから 人は喋る場合はぞっと喋ってほしいやと
そちらには道徳言うなよと
言いたいことは言わせてあげた方が
もう心理学的にも大変素晴らしいんではないかと
言いたいなのに 自分で判断して
これは言ってはいけない言葉だからやめますとかね
それはその人の精神的な健康な状態には妨げる悪いことではないかと
ですから この考え方は認めませんということも言えるんですね
だって人が喋りたくなっていて
喋っている途中で自分で判断して
途中で突然もう悪い言葉を喋るのをやめてしまうと
それはその人の精神状態に対しては悪いと
という風にも判断 それは現代的な思考で
昔はそこまで心理学っていわれるサイコロジーなかったんですからね
それは一つで それからやったことについて
どうしますかね 現代ではやったことがね
犯した罪については法律で罰せられれば十分という立場をとってますから
その本人が別にそれについて気をつけたりする必要はまずないんですね
気を付けることまたできませんしね
なぜ だって喋る時はサッと喋らなくちゃいけないし
途中でやめてはいけませんし
ですから 喋ったことは悪いと思ったら法律的に罰せられます
罰せられたんだからといって
また二度と罰せられないようにと頑張ることはできなくない
できないんですね なぜならば
喋る前に何喋るか本人もわかってないし
喋っている途中でもやめてはいけないし
それでまた喋って終わったところでまた間違いかと言って
また法律で罰せられればいいんですね
ですから 嘘をつくなかれという
なんとかとかね まあ嘘つくのは別に悪いとは思ってないんですから
何か他の人を侮辱するなかれとか何とかと法律だけ作っておけばいいというのは
一応現代的な科学的な思考だとは思いますけどね
でもそこまではないんですね
仏教ではね お釈迦様はやっぱりそういうふうに考え
喋る前に判断してみなさい
喋っている途中でも判断してみなさいと
それから喋って終わってからもまた判断してみなさいと
それで判断したところで悪かったとわかったら
すぐそれを懺悔して隠してはいけないんだと
自分の先輩のお釈迦様やら先輩のお坊さんたち
これは出家のサーウル尊者に言っていることだから
サーウル尊者の責任者っていうのは出家の長老たちなんですね
そちらに報告するべきなんですね
だから罪を報告するべきかということをまた問題なんですけど
例えば自分が隠れて悪いことをしたとも
誰も知りません そんなことは
それがわざわざと自分が社会にその責任ある人に報告したところで
結局自分がそれによって批判されたり
罰せられたりするでしょうしね
ですから それが悪いんではないか
だから悪い結果が得られるんだから
という立場もあります
だから人が罪を犯しても
それが罪だと調べるのは
これは他の人の仕事であって
私の仕事ではありませんと
例えば人を殺すんだったら
自分が勝手に殺して逃げちゃえばいいんです
でも 自分が犯人であるという
そんなに言いたければ自分たちで証拠を探して調べて
反省しなさいと というのは
また世間の道徳的な思考であって
個人にはいくらでも隠せる権利というか自由というか
それがあるんですね 隠しきれたら
もうそれでもう何の罪もないということにもなりますね
そういうのは道徳もある考え方も確かにあります
で それとこれとはなかなか比べられ
時代が違いますからね
まだいくつかのポイントはありましたけど
全部なんか消えました
頭から それからこの言葉の行為っていうのは喋ることであって
こちらでこのアッタヴァーダーサンワッティという言葉
基準ですね 自分の害になる言葉
簡単な言葉で言えば 自分も自分の損になる言葉
他人の損になる言葉とかね
あるいは自分と他人 両方の損になる言葉っていうのは悪いと
ということなんです ですから
自分も得して 他人も得して
両方が得する それを三段階にしているのは
自分のみ得する場合もあるし
他人のみ得する場合もあるしね
それから両方とも得する場合もありますね
だからどちらでも善行為やとは本当は言ってないんですね
私が得するんだからそれでいいんじゃないかと
その人はそれで喜んでいるんだからいいんではないかという
世間の思考がございますけど
その点で仏教はちょっと原始的で
自分が損得する しかし他人が損すると
他人が損するんだからそちらでバツ入っちゃうんですね
マルではないんですね
私は得するんだけど 他人が損すると ２
番目になってくると  3番目の条件
2番目ではなくて 私と他人が損するか得するかというと
やっぱりそれもバツになっちゃうんですね
我々の立場から見れば
それは損しているんですね
私だけ立場から見れば得しているんです
相手の立場 相手だけの立場から見れば損している
私たちの立場から見ればまた損している
ですから やっぱり得は 1項目で
損は 2項目に入っちゃうんですね
それでやっぱり罪になるんですね
ということは 良い点は一つしかない
悪い点は二つになります
では 自分が損する しかし他人が得する場合は立派な行為ではないかと
と思う可能性もありますね
しかし それは世間では自分が損しながらでも人に得することは
これはもう大変ありがたい
何上もないというふうには考えていますけど
残念なことに仏教はまた違うんですね
その場合も で そこほど優れてないんです
で 自分が損するとそこでバツ入っちゃうんですね
他人が得するんだから
それはマルなんですね
3番目の条件に行ってみると
両方またバツなんですね
ですから やってはいけないということには 2票入っちゃって
やってもいいということには一票しか入ってないんですね
ですから それ 3分の2で否定されますね
道徳ではなくて非道徳になっちゃうんですね
それで面白いことに 私だけ得する場合は 3分の2で非道徳になる
相手だけ得する場合も 3分の2で非道徳になる
だから道徳になるのは
私も得して相手も得してという状態でなければ道徳になりません
そうすると 3番目の条件も軽々く通過するんです
だから 1で2で決めれば
3は自動的に  3はどちらにするかというね
ややこしいんですね  3番目の条件は
うべで両方だからね 両方だから
向こうはどんな立場取るかっていうことで
すぐ決めちゃってしまうんですね
だから困った 困ったなという立場が出てこない
だから 3番目がもう とにかく私から見れば
すごいこのセットっていうのは
ものすごい面白く すごい厳密にできていることは確かにできてるんです
だから道徳判断については全くも揺らぎないというか
昔はね 疑問というのは全く生まれないように作ってるんですね
具体例でね 言いますと
どういう場合ですかね
例えば自分にとって得ではなく
相手にとって不利益だと
だけども 自分にとっては得じゃなかったというようなことがね
頭の中ではわかるんですがね
数学的に3分の1と3分の2だと
どういうケースの場合
それ  実際はそういうケース存在しないんですよ
存在しない そういうケースは
だからお釈迦様そういうふうに言ってるんです
そこら辺は説明しちゃうと
仏教の立場から説明するとそう簡単じゃないんだから
でも必ずも簡単でなければいけないと私がすごく責められているんだからね
だから 1 日に 1 日に 30 分で相対論を明確に教えてくれって言ったら
30 分で教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
そういう風に責められてるんだからね
だからそれも頭のいいことだから
あまり気にしませんですけど
とにかく具体的にそういうケースって成り立たないんですよ
で 仏教のケースはいろいろ言う
例えば 自分が犠牲になって
自分の身を投げて誰かを助けると
というふうなケースなんですよ
その場合は自分が損するでしょ
でも助けられた人が得するんですね
それは道徳かというと
自分が×ですね 損している
相手が丸ですね 得している
じゃあ両方といえば両方損しているかって言えば
両方は損得しているかで得してないんですね
あるいは一人が命を助けて一人が死んだんだから
やっぱりどうしようかと
曖昧な状態はあるかもしれませんね
実際はないんですね 両方取っているんだから
得しているかないかといえば
得してないんですね だからそういうのはちょっと
まあそんな いわゆる善行為ではないんですよ
で そういうふうに言えますけど
例えば人を助けることは悪いことじゃないんです
人を助ける場合は 自分もやっぱり危険にならなくちゃいけないんですね
だからまあ その人がやったことは良いことであるならば
自分は危険に 例えば死んでもいいということでやると人を助けられません
それはインチキ 例えば火事になってる家に入り込むと
私は燃えて焼けて死んじゃってもいいんだよと
でも 家の中にいる誰かを助け出してあげるぞと
助けてあげられませんね
もう自分が焼けてもう死んでるんだからね
ですから 火事になってる家の中に人を助けるためには
自分が火傷をして もうガスを吸ってしまって倒れちゃうと
どうやって家の中に閉じ込まれるおばあちゃん助けられますかね
ですから 自分の身を守らなきゃできる仕事じゃないんですよ
そこで少々の危険にはさらさないと人を助けることはできない
その場合も自分が 自分も火傷しました
しかし 人の一人の命を助けましたと
そこで引き算で見れば得してプラスなんですね
火傷ぐらい何のことじゃない
自分の火傷気に ああ 私の体焼けちゃうと嫌だなと思ったら
人間が死んでるんだから
そうするとすごい損なんですよ
そこら辺は引き算で簡単に分かりますね
まあちょっと少々火傷したっても
もう人の命助けたんだからということで得です
それで自分が得た得何なのかというと
この助けたこと自体 自分が得た得なんですよ
助けられた人から見れば
ただ助けてもらってありがとうございます
それで終わるでしょうに
でも 火に飛び込んで人を救った人に対しての
その人がどれぐらいすごい人格を得られるかというと
ものすごく得していますね
俗的には新聞に名前は出るわ
警察から何とか賞なんとかね
なんとか賞がもらうわ
町大会でね 感謝状もらうわとかね
そういう まあ自分が立派な人間であると大変評価されるでしょうね
助けてもらった人は別になんのことなく普通に生活しているだけで
その人はヒーローやとは誰も思わないでしょ
だから自分の身を危険だと思って火に飛び込んだ人しても
やっぱり自分がすっごい得をしていて
相手も得をしているとということなんですね
ですから自分が損して
相手に得するということは道徳的に成り立たない
分かりやすく言えば このもっと他の例で言えば
ここら辺はちょっとヤクザが住んでいるとします
あっちこっちからお金をもう
そこでヤクザでも誰でも
例えば誰でもいいの but こちらがもう勝手に行って行ってお金をあげたりする
あげて応援したりする
そうすると自分と私は損するだけなんですね
相手がそれでももう何のことなくお金もらってるんだから
まあ商売しやすいと それよりももっと明確な例がないんですかね
会社で仕事は全くしない人がいる
それでもその人には会社はちゃんと給料を払って
ボーナスも払って 毎年あの
何と言いますか また昇給もしてあげると
そうすると会社が損して
その人が純粋に得しているんですね
家族の場合は年頃 年になっている息子がいるんだけど
まあ親が必要なお金を全部あげる
遊ぶお金もあげる おしゃれな服も買ってあげる
遊んでくださいと 必要だったらすぐ言ってください
そうすると親が損する
子は何の仕事もしなくてもよろしいでしょう
何かどこかで遊びに行きたくなったら
あっち行きたいなと思って
お母さんもう 100万円ちょうだい
なんでと 今日から 1週間世界でファーストクラスとで世界一周したいんだと
はいはい そうわかりました
はい 持ってきなさいと
その場合は 息子は得のみをしていて
家族は損だけですね それは道徳と思いますか？だってあげているんだから文句も言わないで欲しいんだったらあげますよと
それだけ条件なしと それは一応道徳としては見られ
仏教は見ませんね それであなたにこれを母親がね
これあげるんだけど あなたはこれこれやらなきゃダメやっていう場合は
母も得して息子も得する場合でしょうね
今もお金あげますけど
3ヶ月間以内でちゃんと仕事を見つけて返ししなさいと
でなきゃなんとか何とかという場合は
もう母の希望もありますね
息子はちゃんと仕事を見つけて一人前になるということはね
これは母としての得なんですね
それで息子はもう と言ってるんですけど
まあやるんだけど この条件やと
それ飲み込まなかったら 3ヶ月間以内で家を出なさいと
もう縁を切ると いうことをしちゃうと
そこが道徳なんですよ
なぜならば うまくいったら
まあ子供はもうお金もら玩お金もらっちゃうし
母もそれなりに得をする
なぜならば 子供はその条件を飲み飲まなくちゃいけないんだから
ちゃんとした 1人前の人間になる
社会人になる 仕事を見つかるということにもなりますね
そこで自分が損して他人を助けるという道徳にならないケースというのは
大体そんなもんなケースで
まああまり世の中であるわけじゃないんですよ
とにかくそれは仏教から見れば無知な行動で
ただ自分が損するだけで
そういうのは無知なことなんですよ
まあお金っていう例はあまりにも狭すぎなんですけど
例えば相手が全然勉強しない
こちら一生懸命こちらではなくて
教える側一生懸命教える教える教える教える教えると
でも聞く側は絶対は勉強はしてやらんぞという風にもう覚悟を決めていると
それだったらもうどちらがバカかというと教える側がバカなんですよ
行為をしている側が 自分が損しているだけだからね
だから即座に悪事をやめた方がいいんです
大事なことを教えているかもしれませんだけど
仏教から見れば悪事なんですね
その場合は 聞いてくれないんだから
すぐ即座にやめてやめなさいと
お釈迦様さえもそういうような態度で
仏教だから真理だから道徳だからってそう簡単に言わないんですね
相手は聞かないんだったら
もう出て行けということで
一言も言わんと 聞きたくもないのに
認めたくもないのに 強引に言う
これおせっかいになっちゃうし
だから内容に関係なく
もう悪事になってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなことも成り立ちますし
ですからもう一つ私は言いたいのは
この両方の得というところで
経典ではこの子供に言った教えだから
皆様にとっては内容はなんかもうすごい物足りないかもしれませんだけど
この相手が子供ですよ
この経典の相手がね こんなのは道徳なんか語ってたまるかという気持ちでいるかもしれませんだけど
まあそれはそれで構いませんですが
このですから この子供にわかりやすく
君のためになるか 相手のためになるか
2人のために 2人ではなくて
そうやって両方のためになるかっていう風に言葉使ってますけど
本当の意味っていうのはまたちょっと違うところもあります
だからこの行為っていうのは
この私だけ 他人だけというふうに明確に 2つに分けられますね
私だけ損する 私だけ得する
相手だけ損する 相手だけ得するというね
まあ例えば人の財布が落としたりしますね
それでもう落としていくと
私はそれを見て拾うと拾って自分のものにする
そうすると私だけ得してるんですね
何もしないで人のものを拾っちゃって
しかしそれで相手が損だけしてるんですね
道徳じゃないんですよ
だから拾った財布は自分のものにするっていうことは道徳じゃないんですね
両方の得になってないんだからね
これ落とした人がもう損のみ
私が得だけ 何のことなく
もう手にお金お金が手に入ってしまったんだからね
その人はガチャガチャ何言おうとも
別に盗んだわけじゃないではないかとかね
もう自分が拾ったものだから
自分のものではないかとかね
落とした人が悪いやとまあいろいろ言うかもしれませんね
しかし 損得で考えちゃうと
相手が損している ですからもう非道徳だと
それでもう簡単に子供ぐらいの知識だったら簡単に
それでまあ精神的なガチャガチャでは子供にはわかりませんだからね
ですからこのまあ どちらが得か損かとか
どちらが価値が間違っているぐらいわかりますよね
それでなるほど これはもう徳ではないとわかりますね
それでこの両方っていうことは
この行為の普遍性を考えてるんですね
私とあなたではないという意味じゃないんですよ
私たちにとってはなんですね
私たちにっていう場合は
この一応排他的なんですけど
やっぱりそれ言葉の使い方によって
この we といえばどれぐらい入りますかね
一応私たちという言葉は
これは仏教に関係ない言葉なんですけど
自分を入れて社会を考えるとき使う言葉なんですね
だから自分の存在も中に入れちゃうんですね
だから他人様と言った途端
自分が入ってないんですね
他人に迷惑かけるなという道徳的な言葉があるんですね
それはまあ大変世界でね
認められているもので
仏教の道徳ではありませんですけどね
で 他人さん 他人に他人様に迷惑かけるなとという道徳の場合は
自分を入れてないんですね
じゃあ世間に知られて認めてあげてる道徳っていうのはそういうもので
自分を入れないというところもあります
それはどちらがどう解釈するかっていうことは
もうちょっとそれぞれ考えなくてはいけないんですね
自分を入れた方が正しいか
やっぱり日本の道徳みたいに他人に迷惑かけるなっていうぐらいで十分ではないかとかね
だから他人に迷惑かけるなという場合は自分を入れてないんだから
自分に迷惑をかけることはいかがなものかと
という反論になり立つんでしょうしね
そこで他人に迷惑かけるなという道徳で生きてる社会を見ると
自分の幸せを大事に考えなさい
他のことを気にするなという風にも一応言ってるんですね
だから実際に世界社会
社会を見ると みんなみんな実行しているのは
自分のことを自分の幸福だけ見て生きてるんですね
人のことはもう気にせんという
全くも気にしないと という形にもなっているし
だからそこら辺 思考はどうなっているか
あまり私もわかりません
とにかく自分のことしか考えないっていうこともはっきり見えます
自分のことしか考えない道徳はどうやってそういう風になったかというと
もう子供頃は他人に迷惑かけるなという道徳を教えてあったんだからなんです
だから自分のことを自分が幸せになればいいっていうことで
みんな自分中心に頑張ってるんですね
とにかく自分を出したいという
まあそういう話とずいぶん仏教の話っていうのはもう比較できない
すごい違うんですね 世界は
私が言いたいのは この私
他人 両方というこの両方というのは普遍的な論理
この行為自体は普遍的に見ると
悪いんですか？正しい
もう得ですか？損ですか？と
ですから これ実在で時空関係で評価できない
普遍的に正しいものになるんですね
で 厳密に仏教の道徳論を勉強するしている方々も知っていると思いますけど
このEthicsというのは
仏教ではもう大変な研究分野で
やっぱりこのある時代で有効
ある時代で有効ではないという風に
この 時間 次元的な次元制限的な道徳っていうのは
もう道徳かないかね 疑問なんですよ
例えば 1980年から 2010年までは罪ですよと
2011年からはそういうことをやったっても罪ではありませんというのは道徳でしょうかと
次元制限付きだからみんな平気で
当時で悪かったんだけど
今は悪くはないんだよっていうのはね
それも社会の考え方で
そういう複雑な思考っていうのは仏教ではないので
もうすっごく単純にイエスかノーか
ブラックかホワイトかももう単純に決めておいておくんですね
そういうことで このウベアベアバーダーエピサンワッティアという言葉は
この普遍的な立場を考えているんですよ
例えばこの殺すなかれという
道徳の場合は それはいつでもなんですよ
ある時期はいいんだよということじゃないんですね
殺すなかれということで
普遍的 もう過去でも今でも将来でもって言っちゃったら変だから
なぜならば行為は今やるものだからね
ですから そういうふうには言わない
言わないんだけど ただ殺すなかれと
ですから  2002年から 2010年まで殺すなかれと言うと条件付きなんですよ
時間 12時 夜 12時過ぎちゃったらもう殺してもいいということになるんですね
だから犯罪としては成年は今 18年です
18歳かわからないんですけど
だから 17歳とね  364日経ったところで
もう 10時間経ったところで人殺したっても大丈夫なんですよ
そこで 12についちゃった瞬間でもうやっちゃうと
もう大人扱いでもう殺人扱いするんですね
だからその 0 秒で大人になるということはすごい不思議ですね
59 分で子供で 次の 1 分で大人ですという
そこでこの 15年か 20年か 10年かわかりませんだけど
この人殺しても時効になるんですね
それは日本の決まりで
そこで人殺しは何年でしたっけ？時効になるの
15 15年 かなり短いんですけどね
で そこでこの 30 秒前に捕まっても
もう大変ですよ あの 30 秒経ったらもう終わりという
もう罪はありません だから誰がそうやって捕まったでしょう
たった 1週間かね まあ 2週間か
もうないのに もう自信入っちゃって
もうよくもう逃げ切れちゃったと
ちょっと出しゃばって一言もいたところで
すぐ捕まってしまったんですけどね
だから道徳ってそういうふうな厳密に厳しくやる
この世間のね あの知識的に考えるべきものではないというのはね
一応普遍的なもので もうどうにもならんと殺すなかれと言えば殺すなかれと
で 殺したならば 殺したならば悪いことを犯しちゃったでしょ
では何年まで悪いかって？仏教ではないんですよ
殺すなかれですからね
殺したならば悪いのはもう悪い
もうずっと悪いということになっちゃうんですね
で やっぱりそれなりの償いをしなくちゃいけない
償いをしない限りは 行為の結果はもう罪は罪であると
だから時効はないんですね
例えば人を殺したならば
その罪にふさわしい報いをね
受けない限りはもう罪である
まあその報いを受けて
それはまあ終わりと というふうに
この時限的な時限制限はないっていうのは
仏教ではもう一つの考えなくてはいけない単純思考なんですね
世界はそんなのは認めないと思いますけど
昔こと昔のことではないかとかね
そんなのは今更とかねと言うかもしれませんだけど
一応罪を犯したらもう罪を犯した
あなたはもうそれぐらいの罰を受けることになりますと
その罰を受けない限りは
もうそのままなんです
罪を犯したことで だから罪にも時限制限はなし
嘘をつくなかれというってことは
もうずっと嘘をつくなかれ
殺すなかれというのは
もういつでも殺すなかれというふうに
そこら辺でこの普遍性を忘れるなよということで
ウベアという両方という言葉を入れているんですね
ということは 私にも良くて
あなたにもいいことっていうのは
普遍的にみんなにいいことなんですよ
だから簡単に道徳かないかと判断する場合は
私も楽しくて 関わりのある人々も楽しくて
もう関係ない人々から見ても楽しいものだと
だから関係あって一部が楽しくないんだったらね
例えば私との友達 3人が他の友達の家に行く
そのまではその私たちみんな楽しいんですよ
そこで その友達の庭で私たち行ったこの友達グループが穴を掘ったり
いろいろパーティーやったり
もうテント張ったり バーベキューパーティーやったり
もうもうどんちゃん騒ぎをする
その時はその人の庭はもうめちゃくちゃになってしまうかもしれません
でもみんな楽しかったんです
その時は私たち楽しかったんではないかと
といっても 私たちの一部が楽しくなかったんですね
友達みんなわけではなかったんですね
友達の一部は それは大変迷惑でしたしね
ですから  2番 3番目の条件は通ってないんですね
両方楽しいかっていうことは
しかし 私たち楽しかったよと言っても
そういう理屈は成り立たない
私たちで言えば その友達も入りますからね
で こちらではこの今日説明したのは
この言葉の行為についてなんですけど
だから言葉っていうのは喋るべきでないかという判断する方法はね
損得でいいでしょうね
それで私たちはみんな得するんだったら
嘘言って何が悪いんですか
事実を言うと もういろいろ問題が起こる
来ると それで嘘を言うと
で 問題はこの この なんで私が問題を出さなくちゃいけないんですかね
これは勉強しすぎてることなんですけど
この言葉の判断する条件から見ると
嘘を言ってもいいんではないかっていうこと
問題ではなくて 私はそれだったら宿題として出します
で 嘘を言ってはいけないという普通の道徳表現を
この言葉の道徳 この判決から証明してみて下さい
私たちは学生さんたちに仏教すれば
そういうふうに質問出しますね
これは嘘を言うなかれというモラルプリンシプルをこちらに書いているモラルジャッジメント方程式に合わせてプルーフ証明しなさいと
できるならば ちょっと私の質問をもうちょっと明確にします
だからこちらではこの方程式を与えているんです
言葉の行為にモラルジャッジメント道徳判断する場合は
この法律に基づいて道徳判断しなさいと
それからとっくに道徳判断している嘘を言うなかれという
仏教で判断されているものがありますと
その判断が適切かかないかと
この基準に合わせて争論しなさいと
論じなさいということなんです
だから答えが一つということはないんですよ
それぞれ論じることだから
それぞれいろんな意見があるかもしれません
嘘をつくことによって
人のためになる 大多数
多大大勢の人のためになるとしても
自分のためにはならない
自分の心は欺けない 嘘をついているということが常にそのついて回っている
それは認められます だから嘘の手段にしたことによって
自分たちがやっている人がね
いろんなカラクリしたり
みんなそれで楽しくて興奮かもしれませんだけど
でも事実を捻じ曲がったり
からくりしたりするっていうことで
自分の頭を働かさなくちゃいけない
ですから 真理に 事実に背くという個人の行為が生まれるんですよ
ですから 実際は私はある程度で損しているんです
私たちみんな嘘を言ってもバンバン良かったですが
言った人がもう半分損しているんですね
その損計算してみるとかなりの損なんですから
まあ１項目罰則になったら
3項目も続けて罰則になっちゃいますからね
ですから 3分の2で否定されます
だからその弱みがあるんだからなんですよ
この経典は嘘で始めたのは
もう忘れていると思いますけど
一番最初にお釈迦様が嘘を言うことはもう判断ぐちゃぐちゃじゃなくて
言うなよと まあ一応こちらで説明するものは
言葉についても普遍的なこの法律で何でも判断できます
で 嘘をよくつくなかれということも
そのミスで判断 何の苦労もなく判断できます
ややこしいことを言わなくても
しかし 万が一頭変な人が
これだったらみんなのためになるんだったら嘘をついたっていいんじゃないかという屁理屈を出す恐れがあるんですよ
恐れがあるんだから お釈迦様はラーフル尊者と対話する場合は
最初に嘘を言う人には何の徳もない空っぽのものだと
話にならないんだと もう道徳の判決
そんなもうもう失格で
もう話にもならないと捨ててるんです
だから 罪の中で一番もうもう致命的な罪にしているのは
この嘘をつくことなんです
だから話にもならない
もう罪のもう根本 基本
基準 土台 嘘をつくこと
こうやってきめ細かく判断するところにも関係さえもないんですよ
論外 それぐらい厳しく嘘は別に設定して置いてあるんですね
だから いかにこの こういうところはね
まあ仏教に対していろんな批判があっても
どれほど厳密に考えるかということ
何か喋る場合 お釈迦様も
だから最初に嘘をつくことはいかに悪いかと子供に理解できるように教えてあげて
嘘をつく人は水が捨てた空っぽの入れ物のように
すべてのとこをもうとっくに捨てているんだよと
その人のとこについて判断はもう関係ないんですよ
だからそれぐらい厳しく嘘をつくことはもう前もって否定して
他のちょこちょこした悪いことについての判断基準なんです
癌の告知の問題ですよね
これはかなりシビアなんですよね
ですから この場合はどういうふうに解釈したいのか
やっぱり告知すべきなんですかね
私の今まで見ているケースでは
大体 3万人くらいは言えないんですよね
これはやっぱり一種の嘘にはなると思います
仏教的な立場からいうと
これも嘘というふうに解釈するかどうかということを入れて
だから私はね それは嘘やと思わないね
事実は知る精神的な状態でない人に
なんで言うんですかね
それはもう嘘と扱うこと自体もうもう道徳無茶苦茶と思いますよ
嘘っていうのはそういう並みじゃないんですよ
大変  自分は癌じゃないかしらというふうにね
自問自答っていうか 病人自身
勝手に悩めばいいです
その場合は 私は癌ではないでしょうかと本人が悩んでいる場合は
本人にはそれなりの精神的な思考が働いているでしょうに
だからそうですよ 癌ですよと言ってもよろしいし
本人はアホで癌ではないかと思ったのに
結局癌じゃないと思っているんだったら
別に余計なことを言ってね
精神的に混乱させる必要もないし
で 看病する人を責めてるんだったらね
私はどうですか？そんなの知るわけない
医者に聞けと だから事実だからといって何でも言えということでもないでしょうし
で 私たちにしても 言いたいことをいろいろいっぱいあるでしょうに
事実なのに でも言ってはまずいということがありますよ
だからこちらで言葉は事実の場合なんですね
この言葉の判断の今のセットはね
何か言いたくはなっている
なってるんだけど それは相手に得にならない
私の得にならないんだから悪やと
しゃべってはいけないんだ
だから相手が癌であることは事実なんですよ
それであなたは癌ですよと言ったことで
私は得するか この人が得するかということの判断でしょうに
言ったら得するところではないと
もうなんとなく疑いがある場合は言わないんですね
だから 癌を告知するべきかないかということは
嘘をつくべきかないかというところで考えてはいけません
その辺で私はその問題見るのは
癌を告知するべきかないかと
人間の理解 能力 生き方に対するアプローチ
精神的な見方 精神的な spiritual workout という
そのシステムについて考えるべきなんですよ
だから 現代人がね 根性がなくて
気が弱くて 欲がありすぎて
我こそ世界一神様やというこの態度の生き方がいかがなものですかと
そこら辺でなんですね
私に限って癌なんかなるわけないやというその態度
何なのかと そういう人々は世界破壊するんではないかと
そんな態度で 私の会社はもう倒産するわけじゃないという態度で倒産倒産したでしょうに
日本が負けるわけじゃないという態度で日本が負けたでしょうに
だからその哲学 そのポリシーを考え直してくださいと
それが危険ではないかというところで
がんの告知も出てくるんですよ
がん告知されてものすごく落ち込んでもうひどい目に遭うのは
そのものすごい高慢な我こそ神であるという態度の生き方なんです
それが人類に対してはすごい危険な迷惑な態度なんですね
まず態度だけでっかいんだけど
精神がものすごい弱いでしょうに
だから嘘等の問題ないんですよ
それは別な次元やと思いますね
人格的な問題なんですね
だから がんを告知しないで騙されたまんまで死にかけているということは
個人個人のケースだから大して大きい問題で見えませんだけど
私は何でもこの普遍性にするという仏教的なこの癖がついているんだからね
何でも普遍的な次元に入れて当てはめてみる
そうすると 日本の歴史上
今までどれほど損して損して苦労してひどい目に遭ってきたかというと
この我こそ神だという態度で見るでしょうに
そこで我こそ神では神ではないと
私ももうそこら辺のもうただの人やと思ったところで
ものすごくうまくいく
成功する 負けはない だからそれは精神的に強者か弱者かということで
精神的な弱者が凶暴でその態度をとって
がんになってもちゃんと報告してもらって
適切な治療を受けることさえもできなくなる
例えば抗がん剤やらいろんなもう治療やらもう受けちゃうと
当然もう知ってることでしょうね
この人にバレたら大変やと思っちゃうと
それは全部密告になるでしょ
治療さえも がんセンターには決してそれていけないでしょ
日本でももう世界一流のがん研究センターっていうのはそれだけでやってる場所もあるのに
もうこの馬鹿には行けないんですね
告知してはいけませんなら
あんたはがんではない
しかし がんセンターに行ってください
というのは成り立たんでしょうに
だからこれはがんだから
ごちょごちょそこらへんの病院に行くんじゃなくてね
ちゃんと国立がんセンターに行けと
行った方がね 論理的に正しいなのに
ああそうかと じゃったら行くぞというふうに思うためには
やっぱり精神的な強者でないとね
しかし この一時ショック
最初のショックは誰にでもあります
だからアメリカにしたっても
いきなり調べたところで
まずみんな報告するでしょ
やっぱり医者がもうあんたはこれはもう悪性ですよと言ったら
瞬間でもうゴンとショック受けちゃいます
それはもう人間だからね
でもその時も医者もちょっと待っていて
大丈夫ですかと聞いて
次に次の説明に行くんです
その日で大丈夫でなかったら
では来週来てくださいと
そこら辺は親切に ショック受けますよ
誰でも 自分ががんと言われたって
もう自分の誰かががんだよと言われたら
すごいショックで何か虚しくなっちゃって
途方に暮れてどうしようかというのは
それはもう愛情から生まれてくる苦しみで
それは避けられませんね
愛情あるんだから でもそれは一時ショックで
永久的に続けるわけじゃないんですね
ではしょうがない 何かするしか方法ないということになってくるんです
それには精神的にやっぱり強くなければいけません
だから 決してこの仏教の世界の中でも
この告知するべきかないかということに
嘘をつくかないかという問題だけは導入したら
私はもうバカでいい加減やと思います
どんな偉い仏教の日本の仏教の専門家であれ
私はもうバカ扱いするんですよ
もういいバカもんやと
そっちのは嘘のことの問題ではありませんと
まあ例えば歳になって
おばあさまがもうもうがんにもなったというとね
ずっと明るくて みんなと仲良く
もうみんなに偉そうなおせっかいしながらしたおばあさんだったら
やっぱり最後のもう一年ぐらいもその同じ調子でいた方がいいでしょうに
今更半年間で全部人格まで変えて
そんな無理だからね ですから
歳になったおばあさんもみんなにいろんなことを言ったりとかね
あれやれ これやれ あんたなんでこんなことやってるんですかとか
そういう態度で また明るくみんなに心配しながら生きていたならば
みんなに可愛がられていたおばあちゃまだったら
もうがんですよ で おそらくヶ月間
半年だよと言われたら
それはそのおばあちゃんに言わなくたってもね
そんなのは私さえも言わないんですよ
我々はもうボンと何でも言いますけど
やっぱりそれ考えたら
そこを暗くするよりはね
短い時間仲良く遊んで生活遊んでいましょうと
いわゆるそんなのは知らなくてもいいというところなんですよ
その場合はね だから いいおばあちゃんガンではありませんよ
ガンではありませんという
それってばカバカらしいでしょうに
それが嘘をつくことなんですよ
だから嘘をつくのは無知な人なんですよ
おばあちゃんがね まあすごい
まあまあ がんによって症状が違いますからね
なんかすごい骨が痛くて
ここら辺まあ痛くて痛くて
ああ そうですかな 手も痛いんですかね？腰も痛いんですかね
まあしょうがないな こういう病気だからねというような
そこでそれはガンだから当たり前ですよということも良くないし
それでもおばあちゃんこれガンではありませんよとか
ばかばかしいんですから
ですから 告知しなかったことで嘘をついたならば
その人がもうアホなんですよ
勘弁したいとは 告知しなくても嘘をつく必要ないんです
告知しないでいてもね
それは嘘との問題ではありません
それはやっぱり人間の精神的なアプローチの問題なんですね
我々は生きることはどう見ていますかと
狂暴で 私こそ神やっていう態度で生きているか
ただ宇宙の中でほんのわずかな命として生きているかっていうところなんですね
ほんのわずかな命やと思っている人は本当にすごい強いんですよ
まあとにかくこの言葉喋る場合は他の経典にも道徳ありますから
いかなる場合でも事実でないものは語るべきではありません
仏教は無駄話も禁止しているでしょう
噂話も禁止しているでしょう
噂話は嘘ですかね  定かでないものは語るべからずというのであったら
噂話を否定する  もし定かであったら
噂話ですか 噂 定かであることは語るんであったら
それは噂話じゃないんじゃないですか
自分で確認を取ったら
それが本当であるかどうかが
でも噂っていうのは 人の悪いことを相手がないところでゴチャゴチャ言い触らすことでしょ？いくら確かめて定かでであろうと
なんで なんで言うんですかね
だからそれは非道徳なんですよ
だから噂は嘘やとは決めません
噂は事実かもしれませんよ
しかし 噂話 話は悪なんですよ
仏教では だから普通忘れちゃいますよ
事実語ったんだからって言っていいんじゃないか
冗談じゃないんです 事実なのに罪になることはいっぱいあるんです
事実なのに語ってはいけないこと
まず噂話 それで人の良いところは
ないところで言うのは噂話ではない
人の悪いところ 平和を壊す結果になる
仲間別れることになる
本人がすごい嫌な思いをする
本人の社会的な状態が悪くなっちゃうとかね
そういう風に不幸を招くんですよ
だから他人に不幸を招く事実を語っている
でもそれは仏教ではアクサラン
不善であって ドゥククドリアン
ドゥッカヴィパーカー
ということから考えると
事実はすべて語るという
もうまるっきり無批判的な
無知的な態度は仏教は取りません
事実の中で何を語るべきか
何を語るべきではないかという判断が必要なんです
そこで 他の経典に明確にそこら辺は説明してあるんですね
ブッダが何を語るかと
いわゆるその時項目に使ったのは
判断基準に使ったのは
失礼な言葉を喋るか 優しい言葉を喋るかと
そのタイトルで ブッダは失礼な言葉を喋るか
優しい言葉を喋るかと
聞いたら それはもうすごい単純な理屈でお釈迦様をはめたかったんですね
で 優しい言葉 私は優しい言葉を喋りますよとブッダだから言ったならば
だったらあなたはダイブラットを批判したんではないかと
あの人は地獄行きやと
もう救えませんと もう末期だという風にすごい否定したんではないか
それでダイブラットがものすごい精神的にショックを受けたんだと
悪口やと とお釈迦様を責められた
だからあんた嘘を言うんだと
言ってることは実行してないんだと
いえ ブッダは失礼なことは言いますよと言ったら
あんたと普通の人って何が違うんですかと
ブッダでもありながら
ブッダと言いながら みんなと同じじゃないかと
その時その時失礼なことも言うし
親切なことも言うしと
どういったことない 言ってブッダを否定するというふうな計画でしたけど
でも別にそんな計画知っていなくても
お釈迦様はもうすごい知恵だから
質問された時は あなたは失礼なことを喋りますか？あるいは優しい言葉を喋りますか？と言ったら
一概にお釈迦様の答えは
まあ一概にと言ったんですよ
言ったら全部壊れちゃったの
向こうの計画が それはお釈迦様の鋭いところで
言ったらもうあの人何も喋れなくなっちゃって
ああ 負けたと 負けたってどういう意味ですかと
ただ 何がもう負けたっていうことはと
別に一概に言っただけ
ただ答えただけだからね
と言ったら 実はこういう計画でしたよと
ああそう では私の言葉の基準をということで
お釈迦様 私はね 言葉っていうのは事実でない場合は
まず絶対語りません そこで言葉が事実である場合は
それからその言葉がすごく相手に対しては優しい言葉であるならば
語りません でも なぜならば
その言葉は相手のためにならない時はね
何の意味もない時はね
たとえ事実であって 優しい言葉であろうとも
相手のためにならない
意味は持たない その時は喋りませんと
そこで 言葉が事実であって
相手のためになる 有効性がある
意味を持っている その場合はその言葉が優しいかろうか
厳しいかろうか 適当に喋りますと
ということなんです ですから
みんな楽しくてわいわいする言葉がある
しかし 事実ではありません
漫才の物語みたいに お釈迦様は喋りません
聞いてみんなすごく楽しくはなるんだけど
何の意味もないんですね
何の勉強にもならない
何のためにもなりません
そういうのを喋りませんと
そこでお釈迦様が喋る条件全部通っても
真実であること 有効で役に立つ言葉
その2つは条件なんです
優しいかないかは条件には入ってないんです
人を怒鳴るか褒めるか
それは関係ないと 好き勝手にやるんだと
[笑い]そこら辺はもうお釈迦様はブッダであって先生だから
やっぱり相手のことはいつでも心配する
怒鳴るべき時は怒鳴る
だからそれは条件には入ってない
判断条件には 優しいか
優しい言葉を喋るか 失礼な言葉を喋るかということは入ってない
有効かないかというアッタサンヒタアナッタサンヒタという言葉しか入ってないんですね
エフェクティブかノンエフェクティブか
いわゆる心清らかにするためにエフェクティブかノンエフェクティブかということなんですね
その基準だけ そのためには事実を語る
しかし 条件全部通っても無批判で喋るないんだと
その時時と場合を考えるんだと
その時も その時もTPを考えて喋る
だから喋るということはもう大変なことで
何でも喋るってことじゃないんだ
喋るべきなのはほんの少々
ほんのわずかになるんですよ
仏教から言うと ガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ喋るということは
それ自体不善行為なんですね
そういうわけで すごく言葉少ない方が安心ですよ
看病しているんですけど
どうですかね お医者さんは何言った
何か黙ってリンゴ食べなさいとかね
で 何かまた必要なものではありますかとかね
一言喋って帰ればいいんです
だから言葉少ない方が一番安全ですよ
例えばお医者さんと喋ったでしょう
喋りました お医者さん
病気のことやら何か説明
いろんなことを言いましたよと
何言ったんですか？と
言ったらそこで選ぶ まあなんか退院ではなくて
入院は長くなるみたいですねとかね
もうしっかりしなさいと言ったんだよとかね
他のことを言えばいいんです
病名って何なのか それあんた知ったら治療知ってますか？とかね
知ってどうするんですか？と
そんな医者さえ知ればいいでしょう
迷惑だからとか それもう単純でもうまあいわゆるもう言葉少ない
それで患者はまあこいつはあまり喋りたくないんだなということで
もう親しい人だからね
看病する人だからね まあいいやということで黙っているでしょうね
人間というのはものすごく親しければ親しいほど言葉っていうのは少なるということもあるし
まあどうとしたっても言葉は少ない方がよろしいんですよ
で 今私はもう反省しているところですけど
私は何を仏教の中で何を喋るべきかということは
自分の能力ではもう最初から決まってはあったんですけどね
でも日本人の固定概念で
もう日本人は何でも知っている
究極なインテリで知識人であると
何でも簡単に理解できると
ということで いつでも私にすごい昔からもうね
ものすごく侮辱されるんですよ
これがどういうことか
それは説明してくれとかね
それはもうすごくもう下がるんですね
そこら辺は  [背景音楽]下がると
まあそれで黙っていればいいのに
やっぱり測れないんだとかね
私のプライドまで傷つくんです
よ で 私はそんな偉い態度はないかもしれませんし
しかし人間であることは確かなんですよ
日本ではどんな見方を見ても
それは私 知ったことじゃないんです
我々に対しては 私たちは地球上の一人の人間ですからね
人間としては差別するべきじゃない
それにはすごい攻撃する
そこでこのもう自分のもう態度まで傷つけちゃうと
まあまあしょうがない
もうチャレンジかけられたと
で 嫌で喋るんですよ 喋ってもわからないということを理解できないって
こいつは知ってますね
このお布施の話 業の話
輪廻の話 この知識レベルではね
もう何百年経ってももう理解できないと思いますよ
理解できないことはもう置いておいて
誰にでも軽く元気で理解できて
もうものすごくバリバリと仏教実践もできるようなところは
自分で一応考えて選んで喋っていたんですよ
で その時も別に大乗仏教に対して腹が立っているわけでは全くはないし
そこが基準だから 日本文化では仏教といえば突然もうそこの大乗仏教で使っている仏教用語から思考始まるでしょうに
そこで私はそこからスタートして
こういう風な考え方あるんだけど
これ違いますよとかなんとか言うと
違いますところは仏教
初期仏教のことでしょうに
そこで業って何でしょうかとか
輪廻って何でしょうかと聞いたら
もう答えますからね それにまたいろいろガチャガチャ言うとね
舐めるんじゃないよという態度は取らなくちゃいけないんですよ
気が付かないんだから
本当に気がつくように言わなくちゃいけない
それがすごい厳しいんですよ
だからこの何でも喋るということは
何でも知るせなくちゃいかんということも成り立たないし
何でも喋るべきですよということも
そんな成り立たないんですよ
何でも知るべきよと 何のためですかね
知らなくてもいいことっていくらでもあるでしょうに
関係ないこと 例えばもう分厚い日本の法とか民法とかいう本があるでしょうに
読書は素晴らしいことだからって
私は全然開けて読むことはしないんですよ
なんでそんなくだらんことを読んで読む必要あるんですかね
それでも何かそうやって何か引っかかっちゃったら
さっさとその必要なところを読んでみる
だから私もいろんなことに興味持ってるように
なんかまだまだもうできてない
大人になってないと思うかもしれません
何でも映画も見たり 音楽も聞いたり
いろんなことをやったりしますけど
でもそういうバカみたく何でも知ってやろうという態度じゃないんですよ
私の見方はすごく違う
自分の仕事に必要な情報収集しているだけなんです
他のことは全然聞こうとも見ようともしない
人間の心の汚れと人間がどうやって物事を判断して何しているかとということは知ってはいるんだけど
証拠はない 証拠を探しているだけで
だから私はインドパキスタンの問題に対しては興味を持っている
何のためかというと 人間なり
いかにアホでくだらなくてバカバカらしいかということを言いたいだけなんです
世界支配しているのはもう決まり切ってバカやと
人間のリーダーになっているのは
自分の管理さえもできない
自分のコントロールさえできない
もう愚か者やと パキスタンのあの大統領という奴はね
ただの軍人で不正的にその政府を取ってしまって
それで自分の立場を守るためにいろんなことをやってきただけで
いいチャンスやと思って
あのテロの次元でね もうアメリカに国に入ってもいいということをOK出すだけのことで OK
出さずにいられない状態でしょうね
その時は もしパキスタンもいえ
こちらに来るなと言ったら
アメリカはパキスタンもまとめますから
アフガンとパキスタン両方やと
テロ応援国だと あとイランでも同じことでしょうに
北朝鮮も同じことでしょうに
もうみんなテロ応援国としてもう認定してやってるんだから
そこでパキスタンでタリバン学校があって
パキスタンでテロたちを教育して育ててるんだから
タリバンとパキスタンはものすごい
もうなんとか三位一体というかね
もう一心同体で行動しているんだから
いえ こちら来るなよと言ったらもう終わりですよ
パキスタン そこでまあうまいこと我ってすごい偉いリーダーではないかと
それでもういい選挙やって勝っただけのことで
そこでもうもう誰とも別に喧嘩しようとは思ってない
もうインドに対してえらい侮辱行為をやっている
そんなのはもうガキさえもやらないことでしょうに
インドをバカにするんですかね
インドの態度 態ちは考えると
で なぜ好き勝手にバカにするかと
アメリカとインド違うんだから
もうもうやるぞってそれもないし
のんびりしているし どちらかというと全くの戦争を戦いっていうのはもうやりたくないんですよ
中国に対しても もう対立できるぐらい能力
技術を持ってるでしょうに
だからバカじゃないしね
もう世界ですっごいもう頭の鋭い連中が集めていて
パキスタン人にはもう考えられない
だから仲良くした方がいいのに
パーリメントに行ってテロ事件を起こしちゃうと
そこまで侮辱はアメリカにもなかったんでしょうに
でも教えて抑えてるんですよ
でもそういう人々がまあミサイル発射事件やらね
だからもうすごいもう人間のリーダーたちのこの愚か者がね
たちがね リーダーシップを取って世界はどれほど迷惑かけるかとかね
そこは私は政治批判でも国際政治に私は関係ない
私は人間の心の問題と
まあそれは仏教に興味あるんだから
そこら辺を説明するために必要な情報だけ取ってみる
それ以上は要りません
だから名前やらデータやら数字やらもう関係ない
それ忘れちゃおう 関係ないから
ただ心に関係ある情報だけで私にとっては十分やら
だから知識としては曖昧で完璧ではないんですよ
しかし 自分に対してはそれだけで十分と
だから世の中であるもの
何でも知らなくちゃあかんっていうのはもう成り立たない立場なんですよ
宇宙の遠い遠いどこかで
この全く見えないどこかで星一つ見つかったそうと
勝手にやればいいでしょうね
関係ないんだから そんなの
だから仏教では宇宙についてはもう語るなかれと知る必要もないやと
だからある程度で面白いんだから
どこまでバカなことをやってるかという興味で
私もこの新しい衛星の写真
衛星じゃないね まあ宇宙望遠鏡から何か写真撮ったとすると
やっぱり写真も見ますけど
でも別に驚きも感動もない
全部コンピューターで合成した写真でしょ
別に写真じゃないんですよ
あの宇宙望遠鏡にもうどこかに狙って置いておくと
もうもう2  3週間  1ヶ月間かけてもう回っているんだからね
いくらかいくらか電波が入る
またいくらかいくらか電波が入る
またいくら電波が入る
その電波が入るところにこの位置がほんの少々ずれちゃいます
そこからもう映像を作っちゃうんですね
コンピューターで 電波の波長とか何とかで計算して
これこれこういうこういうものがあるんだぞとかね
全てすべそくすべそくすべすべそくで
データっていうのはほんのわずかで
もうもうもう零点零零零零一パーセントぐらいのデータですごい巨大なストーリー作ったりする
とにかくそれは仏教ではもう心育てる問題については何の関係もないとということで捨てている
だから事実の場合は 世の中で事実というものはたくさんありますが
事実だからといって 要するに
例えばこのマイクロフォンはどれくらい重さですかと言えば
それは事実ですよ 何グラムかということをはっきりしていますから
知ってどうするんですかね
それは別に この絨毯がどれぐらい重いんですかとかね
正確な信奉は何ですかとかね
ちゃんとした正確な信奉があるでしょうに
重さもあるで そういうのもデータなんですよ
しかしそれが知ってどうします
どうしますかと 何のためかと
そういうことだから お釈迦様さえも全て事実を語ってないし
お釈迦様は全て事実を語ってないと言った途端
もう妄想の専門家たちがその語ってない事実は俺が語ってやるぞと教典書く
それで今教やらお経やら始まるんですね
だからそれをもう妄想の専門家たちにいい加減ですけどね
特に華厳というのはね
ブッダが語らなかった事実を語っているんだと
いい加減にせんかとね
聞きたいんですけど 語らなかったものをどうやって語れるんですかね
その矛盾に気づかないんですね
無我ですよと言ったところで
全てはもう無我で実体はないんだよと
いてお釈迦様は因果法則を喋りました
因果法則はそれがすごく難しくて理解しない
理解難しいんだと アーナンダ尊者にお釈迦様がもう叱ったんですね
簡単単純だと思うなよと
しかし 簡単単純でわかりやすく
我々にあるところだけ教えてあるんで
心の働きだけは それで納得いかない人々は
因果法則において輪廻転生を説明しなくちゃいけない
そこであれや色やらプッガラというこの世俗作用やら
もっと前のブッダ仏教の中で部派が 1つできちゃって
それで変化しないプッガラというもう何かあるんだと
それが輪廻転生しているんだとか
もういい加減なことを言ったりする
唯識の場合は阿頼耶識というくだらんものあって
それがずっとあるんだぞとかね
でも阿頼耶識は認識不可能だと
認識不可能なものをこの連中どうやって認識したかと
わかりませんね でも堂々と言うんですよ
この自分の矛盾に気づかないというところはね
しかし語っている仏教だから
残り分はいろんな面白いことは語っていることは確かに語ってますけど
で 華厳にしたってもね
まあ壮大な宇宙まで預けて
まあ空とか何とかとか語ってるんですけど
そんなのは普通の仏教でもありますけど
でもそういうふうなスケールには語らないんですね
そのスケールは取らない
それは無意味であって
妄想なんですからね 研究して言ってるわけじゃないんだからね
だからとにかく輪廻の場合はね
すごくこの因果法則のことなんですよ
輪廻っていうのは現象にはストップがないとか
単純法則で理解できるんですよ
今にある現象は一時的やと言った瞬間で
永久的に消えて無になるということでもなくて
実体もないんだから 一時的で変化できるし
実体があったら変化できんでしょうに
それで消えるかというと消えるわけでもないでしょうに
そこで今の瞬間 次の瞬間に変化する
だから瞬間という言葉は理解しない
イベントというベルトルーサーが使っている哲学用語でイベント
このイベントの連続なんですね
実体あるわけじゃないんですね
イベントというのは一応出来事みたいな意味なんですね
だから私と言ったところで
ある出来事であって 何か個体ではないんですよ
我々はもう多数の出来事に私と言ってるだけで
そこで我々は時間忘れちゃって
過去の出来事にも今の私やというし
これから起こり得る出来事についても私と言っちゃうんですから
もういい加減言葉に気をつけなさいと言いたいところなんですよ
私という言葉を使う場合はね
だからそれはものすごい鋭い哲学者かブッダか
それを言葉について厳密に扱って考えてはいる
だからイベントということで
イベントというのは 1個で言ったら 1個のイベントで
それで私という言葉の中で 1個のイベントじゃないでしょうに
ものすごい複数のイベントなんでしょうに
そこでイベント イベントで
お互いに総合的にイベントの流れであって
だからストップということは成り立たないんですよ
じゃあ時間はストップっていうのは成り立ちますかね
時間は存在しないものですが
でも我々にとっては機械やら使っている時間というものがありますでしょう
時間止まるということはあり得るんですかね
ということは永久的に止まってるんですかね
ではない 実体がない時間という実体がないんだけど
流れると どこまでかというと
もう聞くなよ そんなのもう流れる
それだけ どうしても言葉使えたから
無限という言葉を使わなくちゃいけない
無限という言葉を使っちゃうと
現在の前にも後ろにも無限の印を付いてつけておけなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから私という言葉の使用法がもう完璧に間違っている
私という実体 一つのイベントがあるわけじゃない
これ複数のイベントで
お互いに関係あったりなかったり
もういろいろであって
そこで比較でイベントっていうので見たら
それは流れていくんだよということが
もうそれに輪廻というんです
すごい立派な言葉でしょうね
選んで使ってるんだから
サンサーラというの 転回という意味ね
そんな単純な知恵でね
もうわかるわけないんだよ
だからこれはまあ輪廻認めないという人々というのは
この自我 実体 自分 私 俺っていうものがどうやって今もないやつはどうやって輪廻転生するんですかね
それはみんな考えているのは
このウサギの角のついてもう考えることであって
長さどうですかとかね
それには答えられないんですよ
だから そういう今説明した通りの思考を持ってますか？日常生活する中で
イベント論と生きてるんですかね
そんなのはもう考えたこともないでしょう
だからわかりませんよ
そんなことは だから私は喋ってもないんです
西洋の科学なんかはもう何も役に立たんでしょうに
しかし 西洋の科学にしたっても
まあ素粒子ぐらいのクォンタムのところぐらいで勉強してみれば
物は存在するかしないかっていうことはわかるでしょうに
科学だったら究極的に勉強してこちらに来てほしい
私は科学は知りませんだけど
究極的に勉強した人だったら会話は成り立ちます
本物の科学者にも結構会ったこともあるし
日本でも会ったことあるし
一度もぶつかったことはないんですよ
ものすごい互いに分かり合える
しかし 仏教は科学だと思ったら勘違い
まあいわゆるナチュラルサイエンスという西洋で思っているものはね
私はチャレンジしたいのは
嘘をつくなあれっていうことを科学的に証明できますかと
西洋のナチュラルサイエンスの立場から
それさえもできないのに
科学で輪廻転生を説明とかね
科学に合わないんだとかね
科学者にはね まあ犬には細胞何個あるんですか？とかね
まあそれぐらい質問だったら答えられますけどね
それもアバウトで この薬飲んだらあなたのあなたにはもうビタミンA足りませんよと
ですから これ飲めば大丈夫やと
それに飲んでもその人の健康にならなく
やっぱりあなたの体質ですよと
それなぜかとわからないでしょうに
そういう世界ですので
まあ一応あの余計な話になりまして申し訳ないんですけど
あの言葉の場合は この全てを語るということではなくて
有効な言葉だけ自分と他人の役に立つ言葉
誰一人にも迷惑をかけない言葉だけ選んで喋るとということで
嘘も言ってはいけないし
当たり前で噂を言ってもいけないし
事実だからといってね
悪口も言ってはいけないし
悪口の場合は嘘か真かということはそれほど成り立ちません
単なる悪口だから 怒っていう言葉だから
あのまあその場合はなぜやってはいけないかという
悪口 やっぱり怒ってるんですね
喋ってる本人が 不幸なんですよ
喋ることによって相手にも不幸を与えようとしているんですね
ですから 私のためにならないし
相手のためにもならないし
故に両方のためにもならないという
もう 3つもバツになっちゃうんですね
悪口の場合は まあそれは真理実かないかということはもう成り立たないね
お前なんか見たくもないんだよとかね
もう死んでしまえとかね
聞いたっても あれは嘘ですかなんで
どちらでもないんですね
ただ怒って何か言ってるだけのことで
それは悪口にということになるんですけど
それも言ってはいけないと
無駄話はすごく危険 言葉っていうのはすごい危険なものだから
あのすごく騙されていて
もう大変ややこしくて
ですから この 一番人間に対してはね
すごい大事な道具なのに
その道具の使い方はわからないんですね
動物さえ持ってない道具でしょ
言葉っていうのは それが使い方わからないんですよ
だからまあ仏教はその辺ではものすごい厳しいんですね
この言葉の使い方については
そこでこの7歳の子供に喋りたくなったら
すっと喋るんじゃなくて
この判断しなさいと 判断しちゃうと
もうまだ喋ってないんだからわかりませんではないかというわがままは仏教では効かない
判断しようとしちゃうと
その人は喋りたいものをちゃんと客観化しなくちゃいけないんです
頭の中で それだけでも無駄
限りなく喋るあの危険性が消えちゃうんで
これが喋るっていうことを頭の中でちゃんと秩序化しますからね
だから現代人が何言おうとも
仏教ではそういう心理的なところを見ているんですね
喋る前に判断した方が
もう何喋るかっていうことはきちんとじっと小さくなってくるんですよ
それで判断する あ これがいいやと
でもまだ行ってないんだから実験してないんですよ
同じ結果が出るかどうかわからない
ですから 喋ってる途中でも判断かけてみる
うまくいってるかないかと
うまくいってないかとわかったら
その場でやめられるでしょうし
そうするともうすごい損はもう最小限で終わっちゃう
そこで終わってからはしっかりした判断ができるんですね
もう行為は終わって過去のことになったんだから
結果がもうわかる 明確に
それで悪い結果になったならば
あ なるほど この言葉はあかんぞと
悪いことをしてしまったと
それでちゃんとそれは表現して謝って
いわゆる懺悔して しっかりした人間になる
懺悔することによっても
この行った罪がまたさらに客観化になるんですよ
その客観化することで
自我という妄想で取ることなくなっちゃう
だから自我から離れたら罪とは何でもない
単なる行為なんですよ
悪いのは主観なんですね
だから物事を客観的に
もう単なる出来事として見られる
自分のことも全部出来事として見られる人は無常を知っている人でね
ですからとにかく頑張って
お釈迦様はこの客観化の世界
まあ導くんですよ で まあそこら辺で話を終了いたします
言葉 それからこの 次はもう1日の分は残ってないんですけど
あの 心の行為 心の行為の場合も同じことで
何か今日はここでしましょう
時間過ぎましたので